Okay,
we should be live here.
Hello. Give me a moment. I will
set the stream title
and uh I'll go over
plan for today.
Okay,
that works.
Move this window over
and we'll switch the stream.
All right.
There we
There we go.
So, we have some uh experiments from
overnight.
And we definitely have a new soda,
though. So, it's not as much from the
algorithm as it is from a major bug fix,
which is still fine. I did kind of
suspect that there was going to be
something like this to be fair.
Like it's not entirely a surprise to me
because I kind of suspected that like
Nurmmo should be very hard
but um you know I kind of thought that
our agents would be able to do quite a
bit better.
hello.
Yeah, but it's from a bug fix. It's not
from the algorithm.
It still will be a very nice result,
mind you.
ghost jobs fix. Yeah, I mean I kind of
expected that there was going to be
something like that. I kind of
intentionally never bothered checking
cuz I figured, you know, whatever. It's
still just going to be an applesto
apples comparison. But since the thing
was posted,
I am somewhat conflicted on some sense
because like fixing it doesn't like
fixing it does sort of mess up
um one of our evals,
but I think it's I think it's fine.
Hello. [sighs and gasps]
Just going to pull this model here.
I do find the uh the scale a little off.
Actually, no. It's cuz the end is slow
is why the model's that big.
Or rather, not the end, the encoder is
slow.
We can figure that out easy.
What are you building? Just right now
having um we're pulling the neural MMO
experiments
from overnight.
Yeah, this is good enough.
So, we got 300 experiments.
I think the goal is
we basically want to have all of our
demos
known
working
hypers will change with model size,
right? Though honestly the big one which
is learning rate shouldn't change
because of Miy
I'm trying to see which of these I want
to invest
uh major time into.
Snake is nice as a multi- aent task to
have.
The thing is it's weird cuz it's like
semic.
But we can definitely gold this.
I don't know. What? One, two, three,
four.
Yeah, that's fine.
We can basically gold these
don't know if you don't know much
programming this is going to be quite
advanced um I would suggest my I have an
article on X that is for beginners it
contains all of like pretty much all of
my best advice in one place.
This is the thing I'm doing today is a
combination of very dumb and very
advanced. Like it's very dumb routine
maintenance work on a very advanced
project.
um where I essentially just need to get
this thing ready for our next release.
And that involves checking a million
things aren't broken before we launch.
How's pre-release going? These are all
the ends.
Oh, we can have um
the Tron end, right? We just got a PR
for this overnight.
robot arm
and Tron.
There's definitely something wrong with
the uh this agent or the steps or
whatever with some of these.
How do you work when you don't want to?
I don't for the most part.
In this case, this whole merge thing is
stupid and annoying, but like um I'm
only going to have to do this for like
probably today. I could even finish this
and then we're just set
for uh for this Please.
And then what we do
check these GPUs.
If you're new to programming, you should
not be anywhere near cursor
or any of this AI [ __ ] You should be
basically just writing. You should just
be learning some low-level dev and
writing code completely by hand.
That's embarrassing that we can't even
have
like lag-free typing in terminal apps,
HTML, CSS and Python.
In that case, then you should learn some
C.
Like low-level is not hard and it kind
of makes everything else very easy
cuz it kind of shifts the mindset from
like look at all these things in the
language that I need to understand to
like oh none of those things actually
even need to exist. It's like gross.
I didn't switch to Grock when it came
out. I've been using 4.5 for the last
like few weeks now because it was
faster. specifically because I got sick
of not the quality uh of the model. Uh
they they all are quite dumb, but
because uh Soul would literally take an
hour and a half to do basic refactor
tasks and at that point you may as well
not use it.
Uh C and C are very different,
especially when it's wrapped in a a game
engine type setting, right?
The agenda for today is mostly to just
finish fixing all of the ends.
This PF thing is really starting to bite
me in the sense that we don't know what
um
what max score is, right?
Oh, that actually looks kind of cool.
All right, nice end of port.
I'm basically just trying to get it to
figure out which of all these new M's
just work out of the box and which ones
don't.
Which of these I want cleaned?
Uh, I think it's all fine.
This is nice, right?
Maybe order it differently, but we have
gold ends, silver ends,
and then the rest.
I have not used chess at all yet, Jess.
So, I have to basically see how it works
first. I'm not I haven't ranked any of
the selfplays at all actually yet, come
to think of it,
except for Robo Code, but that's because
it's um this now this thing is now very
very good as a uh versus scripted
opponents.
It's been like had many uh many cycles
of dev on it between both me and
Spencer.
Okay, so there are just genuinely a lot
of M's with no perf on them
I'm just getting uh Hi, Liberty. I'm
just getting all these like automatic
tests.
I think that probably everything, almost
everything will be able to just get a
baseline.
And then I basically just get to spend
my time going through all of our
important M's, making sure nothing's
gotten screwed up. And then for the cool
Ms that uh aren't fully fixed up, I can
just go make sure things are at least
reasonable.
exercise plan. It's a pretty casual one
for the summer. I did a few weights and
5K this morning.
Not particularly intense, just to get
some exercise. This weekend for me is
mostly going to be about the release.
Um,
after the summer, the plan is going to
be to do a more heavy weights uh regime,
and I should probably have some better
energy then because I'll be eating more.
I'm like really pretty lean right now.
I kind of can't get any leaner than this
without just completely crashing
um without totally crashing energy
levels. I weigh like 171.
Much better. At least needs to load more
of them, but whatever.
It is moderately annoying that we don't
have um we really don't have good enough
perf controls.
Like I'd like to have everything 0ero to
one scaled, but what do you do when it's
0 to one is the win rate, right? So the
win rate should obviously be 0 to1, but
like even if you're playing against a
random opponent in practice, the max win
rate is somewhere like around 80ish. I
don't know what to do with that case.
And that happens very often where like
we sort of know roughly how well you can
do, but not exactly.
We could just declare a threshold for
solved to be fair.
Good
thing actually did it. There's soccer,
Tron, ants, bat,
whole bunch of new ends.
No, over 90% is not at all considered
solved.
Like for instance in mazes, maze is one
of our best benchmarks. Um and in that
end I was super excited that we went
from 99
uh.3 to 99.8.
Like that's a really meaningful
improvement.
cuz it means it's handling the longtail
way There.
I think boss fight came with a policy
that worked.
Oh, yeah. Does your robot arm thing have
like a a PF that we can get on it?
Can we like Is the Perf variable well
defined and does it work?
Okay, apparently we got back gammon
back gammon works.
Flappy Pathfinder boss fight back gammon
solve
only robot arm doesn't have anything on
it now.
Don't know about Clifford Ens
for 5v5 world cords for all ships.
Uh you do deltas
and then you hope that you don't need an
entity encoder to make it work.
closest to ship deltas. You can just do
the deltas to each ship.
Yeah, you have to hopefully you don't
need entity encoder.
I mean, there's several ways you can do
it. You can break it into a grid if it's
very coarse. Um, if it's fine grain, you
just do more like delta to points.
There's it's not like a limit to max
obs. It's more so
it depends on the structure of the
problem whether you need entity or not.
House dependent.
based on baskets.
Okay, I'll get that to run.
Annoyingly, it's not going to be able to
go on the web as a CUDA end though,
right?
Is there any I don't think there's like
a reasonable way we can get it onto the
website.
We can have it locally, of course.
Uh, Liberty, I'm just pulling in
everything that was open and like
upgrading it to the latest API.
I'm basically seeing what works semi out
of the box and then I'm manually going
through and fixing anything that's more
complicated than broken.
I have not looked at uh the code at all
yet, man. I'm just I'm doing just like
pulling in everything first. I'm just
seeing what actually has
a model that produces reasonable PF and
then I'm going through manually after.
The goal for today is that we fully have
all of the end of demos ready.
lost functions for what? No.
Is this like
something blow up?
Oh,
nothing really.
Yeah, they need to render every frame is
the thing.
Where's Pong?
Oh, Pong's gold.
Well, it's either that or frame skip,
annoyingly. We'll have to figure that
out.
no. That's not that's not a valid uh
that's not a valid use, I don't think.
writing no code.
I write lots of code. This is right.
This is writing basically